today the Matt wall show Chuck Schumer
says that American birth rates are too
low and the only solution is to import
workers from the third world to replace
declining populations that sounds an
awful lot like a certain Theory we
aren't supposed to talk about also 12
Republican Senators officially get on
board with the federal government
codifying same-sex marriage what use are
Republicans if this is what they're
going to do for us and a church in
Canada comes with comes up with a prayer
to bless and encourage assisted suicide
and San Francisco now has a guaranteed
income program for Trans people I looked
at the application form for this program
and it's even crazier than you might
think all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
Robbie Wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving DC and
going to the Grassroots no group in
America is better positioned than 40
Days for life with a million volunteers
and a thousand cities 40 Days for life
holds peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities they have a larger presence
in blue states with California being
their largest state some former abortion
facility directors say these vigils can
cause the abortion no show rate to go as
high as 75 percent which needless to say
is detrimental to their abortion
business these law-abiding vigils have
closed many abortion businesses in
America nearly half of those closed
abortion facilities were in Liberal
cities where abortion will remain legal
including closures in San Francisco
Chicago and Seattle 40 Days for life is
effectively changing hearts and Minds in
the Grassroots to end abortion you can
check out their locations podcasts and
their free magazine at 40daysforlife.com
and remember
this fight is not over especially after
what happened in the midterms it's more
important than ever to stay engaged in
the fighting if you want more
information about it you can go to 40
Days for life
um at 40daysforlife.com
so we hit a major Milestone this week
and by we I mean everyone in the whole
world congratulations uh the global
population officially across the 8
billion marks so there are now 8 billion
people on the planet it took Humanity
until the 1800s to hit 1 billion but
only 200 more years to multiply that
number by eight this of course has led
to as you might expect lots of frantic
and feeble hand-wringing about the
mythical threat of over a population
quote unquote there are too many people
on the planet they cry the whole planet
is about to tip over on its axis and
we'll all slide off like dishes on an
overturned table infamously there was
once an elected Democrat who expressed a
concern not far from that
slightly less delusional though still
plenty delusional is the fear that we
will run out of resources or habitable
uh land for people to live on I mean
none of these scenarios are realistic
there is more than enough land more than
enough resources to feed and house
numbers even greater than 8 billion
if the land or resources are
misallocated or not properly utilized or
if people choose to huddle together in
massive smelly Urban bundles
that's a different problem entirely that
cannot be blamed on sheer numbers and
also cannot be solved by reducing the
numbers in fact it's not just that
overpopulation is a myth one invented
and propagated by nihilists and
eugenesis and Bill Gates but I repeat
myself it's that the actual crisis we
face as a globe as a world as a planet
the real apocalyptic cataclysm on the
horizon is quite the opposite of
overpopulation our problem is not that
there are too many babies being born but
that there are too few being born the
world's population is getting older the
average age of a human on earth is a
decade older now than it was in even the
1970s now sure that's partly a product
of modern medicine which is good people
are living longer but it's also a
product of an aging population that
isn't having enough babies
and when the median age gets high enough
Society becomes top-heavy with more
elderly people than there are younger
people to care for them
this is a problem that developed
countries like Japan are already dealing
with many others will soon join them
the whole world is trending in that
direction
for for all the talk about
overpopulation the population is
actually projected to start declining by
the 2060s AS Global fertility rates dip
below replacement level understand this
Global populations
have never declined due to declining
fertility
okay we've never seen a decline in the
global population because of fertility
or lack thereof the last decline was
during the black plague 700 years ago
and that was from because of a pandemic
that wiped out a quarter of human life
on the planet
a decline due to people simply not
having babies is an entirely different
matter and it's never happened before
through the whole history of the human
race
and it's not a good sign older slower
top heavy populations cannot Thrive and
after a while they cannot survive they
can't sustain themselves
human civilization is right now
essentially giving up on itself throwing
in the towel
and this again is not a positive
development
in the U.S we're ahead of the population
decline curve we fell below replacement
level fertility a couple of years ago
and um
actually for farther ago than that and
we've been notching record low birth
rates every year since
or almost I mean birth rates hit another
record low in 2020 falling four percent
below the previous year however in 2021
there was a slight uptick of one percent
which is still three percent below 2019.
it was the first increase in the birth
rate since 2014. that was likely only a
function of the fact that the year
before that was so low
overall the U.S has been below
replacement level actually for the most
part and there have been you know there
there are Peaks and valleys and
everything but for the most part it's
been below replacement since uh since
really the early 1970s
and even with the occasional blip on the
radar screen a spike here and there we
are trending in the wrong direction and
fast
Senator Chuck Schumer of all people
has noticed this problem and he uh and
he made note of it yesterday to
reporters when he was giving a press
conference given that Democrats despise
the human species and especially those
members of the species who are residents
of their same country those are the
humans that Democrats hate the most we
don't usually hear them lamenting
declining birth rates
in fact they are engineering the decline
so
what has awakened Schumer to this issue
why does he care about all of a sudden
well that becomes obvious pretty quickly
when you hear what he had to say and why
here it is
now more than ever we're short of
workers uh we have a population that is
not reproducing it on its own with the
same level that it used to the only way
we're going to have a great future in
America is if we welcome and embrace
immigrants the dreamers and all of them
because our ultimate goal is to help the
dreamers but get a path to citizenship
for all 11 million or however many
undocumented there are here
ah so
there you go that explains it the
American population is declining we are
short of workers the senator is
concerned of course that there won't be
enough people available to mow his lawn
and clean his pool and dust his
fireplace mantles and his solution is to
import a peasant class
to import them rather than attempt to
raise them organically the old-fashioned
way
he seeks to replace the American
population with illegal immigrants
he wants to replace them replace us
he wants to replace them on a very large
scale
replace them on a large scale even you
might say you know a large another
synonym would be great
he wants to replace the declining
American population
on a great scale
replace great replace on a great uh so
it's like a great replacement you might
say
that thing that we're not allowed to
notice or mention
that's the thing that Chuck Schumer is
explicitly advocating for
and by the way not for nothing I should
also say 11 million we keep hearing 11
million there are 11 million illegals or
undocumented immigrants as they put it
they've been telling us about the 11
million
um undocumented immigrants since like
since I was in high school okay that
number now is much higher than 11. we
don't know exactly what it is but uh
probably closer to 50 million or higher
in any case there are of course
other ways to reverse the trend of
population decline
and the most simple strategy and frankly
the most enjoyable is for us American
citizens to get down to business and
have babies lots of babies
I I'm not to brag but I am already
pulling more than my fair share of the
weight in this Arena now that I have six
kids and my wife and I have in our
family at least tripled the replacement
rate
and if if you really want to encourage
more people to have babies and if you
want those babies to have the greatest
chance of success in life
that entails more people getting married
and getting married younger
so we could create a society that
encourages marriage and incentivizes
people to start families and to have
children
but that is not what we have done
thanks to Chuck Schumer and his ilk
we've gone exactly the opposite
direction
to start with we kill our babies in the
womb
60 million babies have been killed in
the past 50 years or so
that means we've erased not just 60
million human beings I mean we've erased
60 million to begin with but actually
we've erased hundreds of millions of
potential humans there's a large portion
of those babies after all would have
grown up and had kids of their own and
soon the kids of those kids would start
having kids entire family trees have
been uprooted and tossed into the
incinerator the loss of human potential
is absolutely staggering
and yet Schumer and his party support
fund and facilitate all of this even as
he laments or pretends to Lament The
declining populations
not only that but Schumer and his party
have attacked the nuclear family they've
encouraged sexual perversion and sexual
dysfunction they have invented a human
right to subsidize birth control
I mean they want to give up birth
control in middle schools now they've
created an economy that forces millions
of women out of the home and into the
workplace now they're even castrating
and sterilizing people including
children in the name of gender ideology
this is all part of a deliberate plan
there's no escaping that conclusion
and that's to say nothing of the drug
epidemic killing millions of Americans
by or you know killing Americans by the
thousands every single year uh violent
crime
which is doing exactly the same
they are obviously aware that their
policies are wreaking havoc on the birth
rate while eliminating in Mass those who
have managed to be born
they're aware that this creates a crisis
situation for the country
and here they are at the ready with the
solution
which is to import Democrat voters from
the third world
send in The Replacements
I mean they're right the grace the great
replacement Theory
is outrageous it's outrageous to talk
about the great replacement Theory and
that's because there is no Theory here
it's just a fact
right in front of our faces
now let's get to the five headlines
do you have a coffee lover on your
holiday shopping list Black Rifle has
all the best Brewing gear thermoses mugs
and apparel designed for folks who love
country and coffee Black Rifle sources
the most exotic Rose from around the
globe all coffee is roasted here in the
US by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts stuff your Christmas stockings
with the latest from America's coffee
for 10 off with my code Walsh better yet
you can sign your Secret Santa up for a
coffee Club subscription imagine the joy
of a pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need them most
it's the gift that keeps on giving it's
all from Black Rifle Black Rifle coffee
company is veteran founded and operated
they take pride in serving coffee and
culture to people who love America every
purchase you make with Black Rifle helps
support veteran and first responder
causes so you can go to
blackriflecoffee.com use promo code
walls for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or anything else when you sign
up for a new coffee Club subscribe
that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code walls
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
well
we'll start here uh daily wire reports a
bill that would codify same-sex marriage
protections into law pass the procedural
vote with the support of 12 Republican
Senators on Wednesday despite concerns
that it would infringe on religious
freedoms the respect for Marriage Act
um would ironically named would repeal
the Defense of Marriage Act which is a
1996 law that legally defined marriages
between one man and one woman and
permitted states to not recognize
same-sex marriage from other states the
RMA would make it so that any person
acting under color of state law must
fully recognize a marriage between two
people in another state it also makes it
so it makes it so that the federal
government must recognize marriages if
they were valid in the state where the
marriage took place the procedural vote
passed 62-37
the Republican Senators who voted to
advance the bill were Roy blunt
Richard Burr
uh Shelly more capito Susan Collins no
surprise there Todd young Johnny Ernst
also no surprise Cynthia Loomis Lisa
murkowski and other no surprise Rob
Portman same Mitt Romney same Dan
Sullivan and Tom Tillis
those are the Senators who jumped on
board with the federal government
redefining marriage
Greg Baylor the senior council with
Alliance defending Freedom told the
daily wire quote that the original
version of the bill created serious
threats to religious liberty the changes
to the bill did virtually nothing to
address those threats the amendments to
the bill that purport to protect
religious liberty are mere window
dressing
okay
so let's uh
let's review just a few things here
first of all
the bill is to begin with completely
unnecessary
at least
if it really has the goal as stated
which is to protect same-sex marriage
completely on next unnecessary even if
you're an advocate of same-sex marriage
um you must see that it is unnecessary
because the Supreme Court is not going
to overturn uh obergefell it's it's not
going to happen
there aren't the votes to overturn it
they don't even have the votes to to
take the to take a case up and there
aren't any cases to take up on the
subject
a case could only make it to Supreme
Court of some State somewhere challenges
the decision by trying to ban same-sex
marriage none of that is happening
or would happen
simple as that
so my point is even from the perspective
of an advocate
of same-sex marriage which obviously I
am not one but from your perspective
it's still the case that this is like at
least unnecessary
and I am uh
I am on principle opposed to all
unnecessary laws
I don't like the idea of uh of
politicians taking time up wasting
taxpayer money to pass laws that are
unnecessary
um
and and one of the reasons for that is
that like
if if a law if the stated reason for a
law doesn't make any sense
we're protecting uh same-sex marriage so
the Supreme Court doesn't that doesn't
make any sense because that's not
happening
well that's good that that will will
cause you to suspect that there's
something else going on here
um
so what's the real point then
why are they doing this
well one is just sort of the principle
of it to codify same-sex marriage on the
federal level to do it simply because
they can uh to use the bully pulpit of
the federal government to send the
message that anyone who opposes same-sex
marriage is a bigot Etc uh that's that's
part of the point and that's enough
reason to to oppose it but the other
point is to yes attack religious liberty
listen to the language in the bill that
supposedly protects religious liberty
and this is what uh allegedly convinced
Mitt Romney and others to jump on board
with it here's what the bill actually
says I'm going to read the language of
the bill
it says consistent with the First
Amendment to the Constitution non-profit
religious organizations including
churches mosques synagogues temples
non-denominational Ministries
inter-denominational and ecumenical
organizations Mission organizations
faith-based social agencies religious
educational institutions non-profit
entities whose principal purpose is the
study practice or advancement of
religion and any employees in such an
organization shall not be required to
provide services accommodations
advantages facilities Goods or
privileges for the solemnization or
celebration of a marriage
any refusal under this subsection to
provide such Services accommodations
advantages facilities Goods or
privileges shall not create any civil
claim or cause of action
so that's what it says
and this is supposed to be the thing
that protects religious liberty
even though we already have the First
Amendment which protects religious
liberty and even though this bill also
codifies same-sex marriage on the
federal level
but but
look at who they're mentioning here okay
they mentioned a bunch of people and
they say that okay these faith-based
organizations and then they list a bunch
of things that count as faith-based
organizations
um which also means by the way that the
government is is is claiming the
responsibility and and the power to
decide what what counts the faith-based
organization
um
but it says if you're a faith-based
organization you won't be required to
provide services facilities etc for the
soleinization or celebration of a
marriage
again however they Define solemnization
or celebration of marriage
but do you know who this wouldn't help
I mean it wouldn't help the people who
have actually been under attack whose
religious Liberties have actually been
threatened by the LGBT mob coming after
them on the subject
somebody like Jack Phillips for example
the baker in Colorado
now he runs a bakery it that's not a a
faith-based organization
at least not according to the law
so it's just a it's a private business
but he is all but he's a Christian
and
he has the right according to the First
Amendment to run his business according
to his beliefs to to practice his
religion even in the context of his
business
but this this
part of the law here this language
specifically excludes people like him
which is a big signal to the left into
the LGBT activist that you can keep
going after the Jack Phillips's of the
world
because you only have religious liberty
according to this law you only have
religious liberty and you only have the
rights to not participate in or approve
of a same-sex marriage if you are
directly affiliated with a with a
faith-based organization
religious liberty that's something that
belongs in the churches they're saying
uh it doesn't belong in your bakery
but that's not what religious liberty
means it's not religious liberty if you
can only practice it when you're inside
the walls of a church
because that's not the only time when
you have your faith or you have your
religion at least it shouldn't be
if Christians are not able to
live by their faith and practice it in
every context
um then they don't have religious
liberty doesn't exist
you can practice your religious liberty
inside the walls of this building that's
just another way of saying you don't
have religious liberty it's like the you
know the the farce of a of a college
campus having a free speech Zone yeah
you have Free Speech but uh we're gonna
draw a circle and chalk on the ground
here and you got to be inside that
Circle then you have all the free speech
you want
well it's limited to being inside the
circle which means that it's not free
and that's obviously the case here and
there's another Point too that
what they're trying to do here although
this is an assault on religious liberty
um the other goal is to is to send the
message
that you could only ever oppose same-sex
marriage or have a problem with it if
you are religious
which isn't true that's just not true
this is part of the what the
conversation with Joe Rogan was about
that um
you know you yes it's it is accurate
that if you're a faithful Christian for
example uh or a member of any of the
abrahamic faiths or or many other
religions
you know you cannot be an advocate for
same-sex marriage because your religion
forbids it
but it's also true that you don't
actually need to be
in adherent to an abrahamic religion
to see that same-sex marriage doesn't
make any sense to oppose it
fundamentally
because there is a logical definitional
argument here
which is that as I've tried to explain
uh the relationship between a man and
woman that sort of relationship in
principle is different from it's
different in kind it's different in
function from the relationship between a
man and a man and woman a woman because
of the capacity that it has because of
the potential that it has because of its
if it's of its procreative capacity
and because it has that capacity it is a
different sort of thing and should be
called something different and should be
protected by Society uh and given a
pride of place and incentivized
especially if you want to reverse the
population decline incentivized in a way
that none of these other relationships
should be or need to be
there's no argument there is no rational
argument for legally recognizing
um the love that a same-sex couple has
for each other why does that need to be
legally recognized why do you why do you
need a a piece of paper or a contract or
anything that recognizes that on a legal
level
it's easy to understand why you need
those sorts of protections
for man woman relationships because they
are procreative they create babies they
they are the the the fountain that uh
from which the the nuclear family
Springs which lies at the foundation of
human civilization so that's that's why
it's different
and although although it may be true
that religious people are more likely to
see this reality
you don't actually need to be religious
to see it
and the other thing too is that this is
all being done on dishonest grounds and
you know that if you listen to the
people who push this so here's senator
Tammy Baldwin on the floor of the Senate
um making her pitch for this bill before
it was before it passed the procedural
vote and listen to what she says
right now
millions of Americans our family members
our neighbors our Congressional staff
members and certainly our constituents
are scared
scared that the rights they rely upon to
protect their families could be taken
away
and they are scared for good reason the
same legal arguments that the Supreme
Court rested upon to reverse Roe versus
Wade could just as easily be applied to
reverse numerous other cases related to
families related to intimate relations
to contraception and marriage the
Supreme Court should not be in a
position to undermine the stability of
families with a stroke of the pen
so now Congress must act with the
respect for Marriage Act we can ease the
fear that millions of saying sex and
interracial couples have that their
freedoms and their rights could be
stripped away
by passing this bill we are guaranteeing
same-sex and interracial couples
regardless of where they live
that their marriage is legal and that
they will continue to enjoy the rights
and responsibilities that all other
marriages are afforded
so you hear what she what she's and and
of course we've heard this the whole
time but she uh she mentions interracial
couples probably I don't know three or
four times Just In that clip alone and
in fact every time she says same-sex
couple she makes sure to include
same-sex couples and interracial couples
uh
when
there's just been no con there is no one
who wants to abolish interracial
marriages
that organism isn't being made by anyone
I mean there also again is no actual
political threat to same-sex marriage uh
because no states are going to do that
Supreme Court wouldn't do that and the
Republican party uh unfortunately
does not have the wherewithal to to make
this argument at all they refuse to make
it
um that's the case for same-sex
marriages
interracial couples there's just no
one's talking about that except on the
left
because again an interracial coupling
does obviously does not at all challenge
the fundamental definition of marriage
you know a a uh a black man and a white
woman
in principle can create babies have
procreative potential just like uh two
members of the same race
and one other point about that too is
that if anyone I say that nobody is
criticizing interracial couples and no
one has a problem with that
it's actually not exactly true
you know you could go online and see
people complaining maybe about that
but they're almost always going to be on
the left
okay and so it's on the left it's the
race Hustlers on the left it's the
proponents of critical race Theory and
so on if anyone is going to criticize in
the year 2022 interracial couples it's
almost certainly going to be someone on
the left approaching it from that
perspective
so
the uh challenge to interracial
couplings if it exists at all is uh
coming from inside the house if you're
on on the Democratic side
all right
daily wire has this report as Canada
prepares to loosen laws related to
medical assistance in dying
prayers published by the United Church
of Canada designed to help sick and
disable people follow through with the
lethal procedure I'll draw our drawing
criticism and shock so this is a church
quote unquote that has come up with
prayers encouraging people to kill
themselves all right
although euthanasia has been available
to many Canadians for the past six years
the nation's Parliament considered
amendments to the criminal code last
year that would expand the availability
of the practice among other changes a
citizen possessing only a mental illness
can now request euthanasia starting next
spring whereas the practice was
originally limited to individuals with
serious physical illnesses or
disabilities and we've been talking
about this uh on on this show that in
Canada
you know uh euthanasia is threatening to
become it already is a one of the
leading causes of of death in some
provinces in Canada
um
as they are taking this the the what
they call the maid law the maid act
medical assistance and dying and they
are progressively expanding it to
include more and more types of people
so long gone are the days when
euthanasia when the euthanasia
conversation revolved only around people
who are already on their deathbed who
are terminally ill who are going to die
anyway within the next few weeks it's
long gone are the days when that's when
that is what the euthanasia
conversations about
and even then even when it was just
focused on on that population of people
I opposed it
and this is one of the reasons why I
posted
because everything is a slippery slope
on the left this of course is is no
exception
if we are saying
that
suicide
you know that killing someone can be a
valid medical treatment if that's what
we're saying
then it's only a matter of time before
that is applied far beyond terminally
ill people
the whole logic between behind
euthanasia was terminally ill is that
they're they're suffering they don't
want to live anymore there's there's no
point in living when when they're
suffering so much and so the best way to
treat that suffering is just to kill
them
well it's not that far of a jump at all
in fact it's not even a jump it's just a
step
to see how well that if that if that's
the true for terminally ill people then
yeah why not someone who's depressed
why not someone who's struggling with
mental illness
they're suffering too as far as they can
see it there's no end of the suffering
life is suffering
and so I will treat this is how we will
treat the suffering
anyway back to the um United Church of
Canada
it's called The Prayer in the midst of
fear which is co-authored by United
Church of Canada Minister and the former
co-president of dying with dignity and
advocacy Group which supported the
legalization of assisted suicide in
Canada it can be described as an
exercise in radical autonomy the
supplication centers upon asking God
that family members would accept their
loved one's decision to kill themselves
with the aid of medical professionals
making no mention of eternal life
secured through the death and
Resurrection Jesus Christ the prayer
attempts to embrace an uncertainty about
death
so here's part of the prayer
again this this was uh devised by the
United Church of Canada
says I am afraid I feel fear penetrating
my mind in my heart I feel fear in my
gut I am afraid to die I do not know
what lies beyond the barrier of death
I am afraid to release myself to the
great unknown
I am heartbroken and afraid to leave my
family I am still needed
I have let go of Hope and healing I hold
on to hope for the next life
I'm afraid that my family and loved ones
children and grandchildren will be
troubled when I tell them I plan to die
using Medical Aid and dying
but in the midst of my fear I have hope
that my family and loved ones children
and grandchildren will understand the
choice to end my suffering I hope
they'll be proud of my decision and will
understand that maid is consistent with
the love and compassion of Jesus
and then it goes I can't even keep
reading this I mean this is this is
obviously not a Christian prayer this is
a demonic incantation
this is a a you know this is this is a a
mockery of of Christianity this is
Christianity turned on its head
because Christianity is a is a is is
hope it is a religion a faith
of Hope and this is
the abandonment of Hope
says I hope that my family will be proud
that they'll be proud that I killed
myself
because I don't want to suffer anymore
this is what happens when you when you
put we talk about the slippery slope
when you put doctors in charge of
killing people when you say to doctors
that this is now a valid treatment that
could be available to some people
this is this is where it leads
and uh it was entirely predictable
all right Alexandra kaiser-cortez has
some thoughts about
um trans rights let's listen to that
is that the same folks who tell who tell
us and told us that clovid kovid's just
a flu that climate change isn't real
that January 6 was nothing but a tourist
visit are the same are now trying to
tell us that transgender people are not
real
much of that is is correct
um
climate change is a is a is a a hoax
well
what we're told about climate change by
the left much of that is a hoax that's
correct
um January 6th the tourist visit well no
it was a riot but it was closer to a
tourist visit than it was to uh an
Insurrection that threatened to overturn
you know the the government of the
United States
if everything's on a spectrum then it
would be closer to the to the tourist
and the tourist Expedition end of that
Spectrum than an Insurrection that would
have overturned uh
in the government
and trans trans people are not real well
this is this is this is what we keep
hearing from the labs they're claiming
that what we are saying is that trans
people aren't real
well it depends what you mean by that
we all agree that there are people in
the country
who identify themselves as trans so
those people certainly exist there are
people who are walking around and saying
I'm transgender yes we all agree that's
not a figment of our imagination we're
not hallucinating it
um
we all agree that's the case that those
people exist
however the question is whether the
claim that they're making about
themselves is true
and then the second question is related
to the first
is it actually possible for a person to
be transgender
is that a valid a legitimate
uh a coherent kind of human identity
whereas transgender trans it means
Beyond gender you're you're beyond it
you're something you're something past
it Beyond it
is it possible to be that the answer is
no no one no one is beyond it because
we're human beings and there are two
options male and female and nobody
exists beyond that
so in that sense
uh
you know trans if that's the sense that
you mean that in that sense trans people
don't exist in the sense that you there
are no people who actually exist beyond
the gender binary because the gender
binary is real and we all are are are in
it on one side of it or the other
and yet the people who are confused
about this yes they certainly do exist
and if they didn't then we wouldn't be
having this conversation
speaking of people who are confused
here's something that's been making the
rounds on um on Reddit
this is posted by a an account called
males of Reddit
as a screenshot of someone on the the
trans Forum the male to female transform
on Reddit
and here's what they posted they said I
have successfully breastfed my child
there's a male Again by the way my kiddo
was born last week and I was the first
to breastfeed her my partner and I gave
her well they've
they are recognizing the sex of their
daughter so that's something at least
you gotta look for the glimmers of Hope
where you can find them especially in a
situation like this my partner and I
gave her 40 hours of continuous skin to
skin after she was born but after after
months of preparation and trying I was
able to breastfeed my own kiddo from my
breast it's a wild feeling it made me
over the moon happy she's a cutie
and then there are screenshots a bunch
of comments saying that uh you know how
wonderful all this is
now it should go without saying but I
feel that I must say it anyway
um
it is not possible for a man to
breastfeed a child
okay that's not something that you that
can actually be done you cannot sustain
a a child that way
now what is possible and what has
apparently happened in this case
is that if you take if you're a man and
you take a whole bunch of hormones and
you drug yourself up this way that after
a while you may start secreting some
there may be some secretions that come
out of your nipples which is disgusting
but that's that that may actually happen
so these are going to be hormone these
are going to be these secretions hormone
laced with artificial hormones
that are now being ingested by the child
it could that possibly be remotely
healthy for a newborn child to be
ingesting that whatever that is
okay and we're not going to call it's
not it's not it's not it's not it's not
the mother's milk it's certainly not
that whatever you want to call that
mucus those secretions
uh is it healthy for a child to be
ingesting it
is there any reason to think that it
would be
obviously not
but as always it's not about the child
this is certainly extremely physical and
healthy for the child not to mention the
psychological damage being done even at
such a young age
but that doesn't matter it's not about
uh it's not about the child it's about
this guy
no this is a this is a a fetish
for him
this is a desire that he has and that he
has now forced a newborn child to
participate in
I also want to play this clip for you
MSNBC
um
it appears to be maybe turning on
Ukraine ever so slightly I thought this
was an interesting clip let's play this
such an important point the reason if
this was in fact a Ukrainian defense
missile that uh engaged in an accident
the reason they're firing those up is
because Russia is attacking Ukraine deep
in its own territory near the Polish
border going after infrastructure and
civilian targets uh just a couple of
minutes ago Richard the Polish president
president Duda called this an
unfortunate accident and not an
intentional attack this never made sense
to you even yesterday that it was a
Russian attack no as I must have Reedy
said if you're going to do an
intentional attack if you're Russia and
you're going to risk taking on NATO and
by the way Russia can't defeat Ukraine
why in the world would they take on NATO
it just makes zero zero sense uh so yeah
it's it just there's no way this I
thought could have been an intentional
Russian uh attack I think the the polls
look studied measured which is what you
want to look here NATO looks good
Ukraine looks a little bit too hot the
idea that the Ukraine is saying this has
to be a Russian it almost looks as if
they wanted just to be something more so
I think that's unfortunate and that
won't help their credibility uh
so look I think this the only other
lesson I take from this is any time
you've got a hot War
stuff happens to use Mr rumsfeld's
comment the danger of escalation is
somehow implicit the danger of accidents
and again it's it's the reason you you
don't want to fly off the handle when
stuff happens just just get the facts
and make sure you're responding to
something that was actual and if
possible intentional you don't want to
have inadvertent escalation here so
there's a little bit of a lesson when
something hot is going on
well I said ever so slightly uh that's
uh probably turning on Ukraine as uh is
is an overstatement
um
but he does acknowledge
that's yeah Ukraine they it's almost
like uh he says they were too hot they
were almost it's almost like they they
wanted it to be a Russian attack when
the Missile hit Poland and killed two
people and Ukraine we immediately heard
from Ukraine and zelensky there's a
Russian Russians the Russians did it
it's almost like they wanted it to be
the case yeah you think so
it's it's not that they they're the ones
who launched the missile
so that's not that they wanted that they
wanted us to think that they're the ones
who launched it
the only question about this is whether
this was a false flag operation that
they launched it
intentionally so that they could blame
Russia and draw Western governments into
a world war with Russia or if uh if this
was an accident and then zelenski turned
around with bad Intel and uh because he
wanted it to be a certain way and he
just told the world that I mean again
either way
it's it's really bad for zelenski in
Ukraine
but
you know when there's a when there's a
suppose when someone makes a mistake
that would work out really well for them
then I I tend to think that's not a
coincidence
so it seems pretty clear to me that this
was intentional this so they were trying
to hoax us into a World War
and although we might be hearing from
the media now now they're saying oh yeah
I never thought it was so of course it
wasn't Russia
that's not what they were saying on
Tuesday
when this news first came down
I mean on Tuesday every corporate media
Outlet was ready for World War
not even stopping to think about it why
would Russia why would they even do this
I guess if they're if they're the comic
book villains and uh and so they're just
launching missiles for no reason
but in the real world Russia in this
conflict with Ukraine why would they
just randomly attack Poland
it never made any sense but
it's not just that Ukraine wanted it to
be a certain thing it's that the media
wanted it to be that too
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
you know release band is the number one
FDA cleared anti-nausea wristband it's
clinically proven to quickly and
effectively effectively prevent or
relieve nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness and
chemotherapy so whether you need
everyday nausea relief or just an
occasional cure relief band is the way
to go because it's got patented
technology that makes feeling sick a
thing of the past like the name says
relief band is legitimately just a band
that you wear on your wrist to give you
relief from nausea you can even change
the intensity depending on how you're
feeling relief band has an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau and over
100
000 satisfied customers if you want the
band that actually works to relieve your
nausea check out relief band right now
you know I've worked on an exclusive
offer just my listeners as well if you
go to reliefband.com use promo code
Walsh you'll get 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee you get all of that
but you got to go to the website go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
Walsh for 20 sent off plus free shipping
the spirit of traj says the fact that
girl wasn't forced off the stage
immediately but rather clapped for says
everything uh yeah that was the girl
that was that was insulting and
attacking her own father at his funeral
during a eulogy
yeah it's it's bad enough that they clap
but really somebody should have walked
up onto the stage during during that and
just escorted her off the stage
um I I think in in many ways we need to
become a more confrontational culture
than we are more confrontational what
usually hear is it's the opposite so
it's too confrontational too divisive
and we all need to turn down
the temperature quite a bit that might
be the case on the internet okay yeah
everyone is really confrontational on
the internet and if you say one thing
um that they don't like they're going to
tell you that they help you die of
cancer and all that kind of stuff but in
real life it's it's it's really the
opposite because people are hiding
behind and they're they're kind of
venting all their frustrations behind
the comfort of their keyboards in real
life
all of these people are a bunch of uh
fainting little flowers
and so you can see something like this
happen and uh and a bunch of people just
standing by and watching it
because although they might be eager to
confront on the internet
most people don't want to confront in
person
and we could actually use a lot more of
that cool Papa J magic says I would so
love to hear Matt call this woman
anti-white which is what she is the Go
free lexicon is spreading so it's just a
matter of time when I've ever hesitated
to call someone anti-white if they're
anti-white
yeah she's anti-white obviously
I've talked about anti-white racism
using that term many many times
I always find it funny when I I you hear
this from people in the audience well
Matt never talks about this it's like
I've talked about that all the time
I maybe haven't talked about it in the
in the last I don't know 48 hours but
that's not the same thing as never
talking about
um Owen says I have a bad relationship
with my father but I have family members
who do have a good relationship with him
and I respect that there's no possible
way that anyone could convince me to do
what she did absolutely disgraceful and
that's a good point too it's not just
about you know the funeral is not just
about honoring
the dead it's also about the living
that's now the people say the funeral is
only for the living I disagree with that
I think it also is about the dead it's
about honoring the dead
um but the funeral is indeed in part for
the living
and so even if you didn't have a good
relationship with this person think
about all the other people who are there
who don't feel that way and who for for
them it's going to help them grieve
to be able to honor this person
and you're just throwing a hand grenade
into the middle of that because it would
make you feel better
uh Delta 9 says that chick's eulogy
could could have come right out of Mao's
cultural revolution I suppose she'd
probably take that as a compliment well
she wouldn't because she wouldn't know
at Mal's cultural revolution is even
though she's
participating in it
um
let's see
Majid says Matt I think it actually is
in the best interest of some random
American sitting on his dinner table
that Russia is punished I.E had its
Global presence diminished because then
the U.S will directly benefit from
weakening one of its main competitors on
the global stage and that may translate
into an improvement in terms of
well-being for an average American
well that's your assertion I understand
and you have reasserted it
but how exactly does it help
and so you're asserting that it would
improve the well-being of the average
American citizen if we are to uh punish
Russia okay so that's that's your
assertion that's what you're claiming
how exactly walk me through that
give me the step-by-step process
okay I want you need to connect those
dots for me because
I'm not being facetious I don't see it
um
Tyler says sounds like Matt is that guy
who's just losing his mind in my rear
view mirror because myself and the four
cars in front of me are only going seven
miles per hour over the speed limit I am
absolutely that guy how dare you go only
seven miles if you're going seven miles
over the limit
you're going at least 10 miles per hour
too slow
that's my drive that's my driving safety
recommendation
um
let's see
Nikki says I agree about people who
drive too slow in the fast lane but the
worst Highway offenders are people who
try to jump ahead in traffic by driving
all the way to the end of the merge lane
slash ramp and then cutting in at the
last moment
but you you could not be more wrong
Nikki I'm afraid to say you couldn't
possibly be wrong or you have gone as
far from correct as you could possibly
go
you have reached the absolute zero of
wrongness the merge lane the the ramp
okay it's there for a reason you're
supposed to use it
and if there's a lot of traffic
uh especially I I'm I always take the
on-ramp all the way to the end before I
cut in because that's my lane and I have
every right to it and I'm going to use
it and if I'm coming onto the highway
um I I have a right to that lane and I
will use it all the way to the end I'll
leap I'll leap in front of 50 cars cut
right in at the last minute
and I will do it without causing any
other car to break their stride or slam
their brakes I will do it with surgical
precision and you will look on in
jealousy but that's not my problem
so you're sitting in traffic and you're
just jealous of the people that are on
the on-ramp and you see them whizzing by
you and cutting in front
but your jealousy is not my issue
no the real problem with merging is I
think we talked about this before it's
when and this is a big issue in
Nashville I think Nashville is the
capital of this and I'm not exactly sure
why but the real problem is when people
are they're merging onto the highway
and there's a lot of traffic and for
some reason they just kind of panic and
they get afraid and so they come to a
complete stop in the middle of the merge
lane and sit there with their dumb
little blinker on like an idiot waiting
to cut into the traffic meanwhile
there's still like a hundred feet of
runway in front of them that they refuse
to use and so they're causing all the
other cars that are coming on the
on-ramp they have to slam on their
brakes
that's the real issue
you know something smells over at my
swag Shack something like sweet baby
Spirit that's right fealty to the SBG is
In Bloom this holiday season so come as
you are and get yourself the sweet baby
album tea it's the perfect gift to
yourself and everyone you know because
there's just something in the way they
put my bearded infant self on a t-shirt
that no one can resist so if you want to
take part in this and help us to exploit
your Millennia Nostalgia head over to my
collection over dailywire.com shop and
get the sweet baby gang album t-shirt or
any of the other amazing holiday
offerings at the new and improved daily
wire plus shop like free shipping for
orders over 75 dollars and a free
leftist tears tumbler with all orders
over a hundred dollars get your shirt
today uh and everything else these are
already close to selling out again go to
dailywire.com shop and get yours before
they're gone also if you follow daily
wire on social media you've surely seen
the excellent work of our skilled
content coordinators most notably the
Work featuring me and all of of my
heroic exploits well we're currently
looking to add one more coordinator to
the team so if you have experience in
social media marketing or content
creation we want to hear from you this
is a Nashville tennessee-based position
where people actually come into the
office put on their shoes you better put
them on if you want to come to the
office and do real work instead of
attending struggle sessions on Zoom all
day
if you want more information or if you
want to apply visit dailywire.com
careers today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well we flew into San Francisco
yesterday for my speech at Berkeley
tonight we had to drive downtown from
the airport to get to our hotel the GPS
it wasn't working but fortunately we
were able to follow the stench of weed
and feces and it led us right into the
city
truly San Francisco Is A god-forsaken
Wasteland it is like something out of
Mad Max but way gayer if you didn't know
any better you might think that the
whole city is like some kind of penal
colony
if I had to choose between going to
prison or moving to San Francisco it
would be a flip of the coin at least
because there's no discernible
difference between the two this is what
a leftist Utopia looks like and what it
smells like like urine and garbage and
despair so what I'm trying to say is
that I'm not a big fan of this city and
so it should come down as no surprise
that I am canceling the city today
though my reason for canceling has
nothing to do with the trauma that I
suffer every time I'm forced to come
here uh it is it's really a coincidence
perhaps Providence that I happen to be
in the city on the day when it's reason
for cancellation has presented itself
and here's that reason it's a report
from the local ABC affiliate in San
Francisco it says San Francisco mayor
London breed announced the launch of a
new guaranteed income program for the
city's transgender community on
Wednesday the guaranteed income for
Trans people gift program will provide
low-income transgender residents with
one thousand two hundred dollars each
each month up to 18 months to help
address Financial insecurity within the
community
in a statement the city of San Francisco
said gift is one of several programs the
city is developing implementing and
evaluating to identify how to best
support San Francisco residents and
promote economic stability and Recovery
City also said that the new pilot
program is the first guaranteed income
initiative to focus solely on trans
people and will provide 55 eligible
participants with temporary income
additionally the city said it will
provide the same individuals with wrap
around Direct Services such as gender
affirming medical and Mental Health Care
case management specialty care services
and financial coaching
now we're told the reason for this
program is that trans people are
disproportionately impacted by poverty
we already know that trans people are
disportially impacted by by everything
really if there was a giant tsunami that
obliterated the whole city not to get
your hopes up and everyone was washed
away in the process we would still be
told that trans people were
disproportionately impacted if a volcano
erupted on an island in the Pacific and
incinerated a small village of 600
people and there were no trans people in
the village at all we would still be
told that trans people were
disproportionately impacted somehow
as for poverty the article says this
quote
we know that our trans communities
experience much higher rates of poverty
and discrimination so this program will
target support to lift individuals in
this community up we will keep building
on programs like this to provide those
in the greatest need with the financial
resources and services to help them
Thrive said mayor London breed in a
statement transgender communities
experience poverty and economic
stability instability at
disproportionately uh High rates
according to the city the U.S
transgender survey which is which is the
only large-scale study of trans people
in the U.S in 2015 found that 33 of
trans people in California were living
in poverty
all right
so we're supposed to assume that the
higher rates of poverty in the trans
Community are due to you know
discrimination transphobia whatever even
in a place like San Francisco where
trans people are literally worshiped as
deities even here it's uh the the high
rates of poverty are because of bigotry
yet even the left will acknowledge that
trans people they also have higher rates
of mental illness and substance abuse
issues
that would seem to explain why they're
more likely to have trouble holding down
a job
and it's hard to see how handing them a
check for 1200 bucks will solve that
and by the way if we're if we're
providing Financial advantages to groups
that are more likely to be homeless and
impoverished why not set up a program
giving a monthly stipend to men
quote cisgender men specifically after
all
uh men as compared to women suffer much
higher rates of homelessness and and
similar conditions
so why not give them a program
but no such program would or ever could
exist because the disproportionate
impact game is rigged
in any case we still haven't gotten to
the reason for this cancellation
you know obviously
handing out free money to the gender
confused is an insane idea that will not
solve any problem and will only make the
existing problems even worse but if San
Francisco wants to continue its March
into insanity and Oblivion it is more
than welcome to do so I have no interest
in talking sense into them nor could I
even do that anyway that's why my focus
is not on the program itself
but on the form you have to fill out in
order to be eligible for it
so if you want to take advantage of gift
you must complete a 10-page form which
is available online in PDF form so you
can go see it and the reason why you
might think like 10 pages that's uh
that's a lot of pages why do you have to
fill out 10 pages well
the reason that it's 10 pages
that becomes immediately obvious when
you skim through it
for instance you're asked to provide
your pronouns and the form gives you 15
options including Coco's
now these may sound like characters in a
Dr Seuss book but instead they are in
fact made up pronouns now what is a v
verb exactly and how is it distinguished
from a z Zim or a perpers nobody knows
nobody can say
and of course if 15 options aren't
enough you can also check not listed as
an option
yet the list of pronouns seems downright
limited compared to the section for
gender identity
there are according to Libs of tick tock
we took the time to count them all God
bless her there are 97 provided options
for gender identity 97 genders
and now In fairness they've padded the
stats here quite a bit uh there will be
in many cases four or five different
ways to phrase the exact same thing such
as transgender woman woman of trans
experience woman with a history of trans
of gender transition or trans feminine
these are treated as discrete and
distinct identities yet they're all the
same brand of nonsense rephrased in
various different ways other gender
options include
sister girl
feminine of Center
brother boy xenogender
gender Outlaw is an option you can be a
gender outlaw
multi-gender Omni gender
Novi gender she really identify with the
if you really love the the month of
November I guess you're a Novi gender
and also there's a gender called
aggressive
that's that's the agenda aggressive
aggressiveness is its own gender now
and if somehow none of those work for
you you can always check I don't use
labels or not listed
now what about sexual orientation well
here there are a quaint 17 options
um a number inflated by the fact that
non-monogamous pansexual and polyamorous
are all listed as separate options
another sexual option on a sexual
orientation option on the list and I'm
just telling you this okay this is this
is what's on the list this is what this
government form says this is a valid
label according to the form
and the label is [ __ ]
that is on the sexual orientation
checklist don't shoot the messenger I'm
just I'm telling you what the form says
that is now a sexual orientation that
you can claim and then get twelve
hundred dollars from San Francisco if
you do
now
I've often said that many of these new
gender and sexual orientation labels are
not really genders orientations but
actually personalities and there are
others who say that there are not
genders sexual orientations or
personalities but really are mental
illnesses and I think both are the case
you know you don't have to choose
between the two but there's something
else too
um in in many cases take someone who
identifies as a pansexual multi-gender
Demi boy with am pronouns I think it'd
be almost making too much of it to call
it a personality or a mental illness
it's almost giving it too much credit
because this is actually just nothing at
all it doesn't mean anything
in so many cases genders and pronouns
now are like Hobbies these days it's a
recreational activity
people have nothing better to do just
sit around coming up with and collecting
new labels for themselves it's like this
generation's Pokemon cards
except it comes with a with a you know
extra side of identity crisis
and maybe
this is partly why San Francisco has so
many homeless people
can't get jobs
because the entire city is sitting
around thinking about its pronouns and
gender identities these are the kinds of
things they're thinking about
don't have the time to think about or
worry about anything else like getting a
job or
housing for example
I think there may be more to that theory
than you think but we're not going to
flesh it all out now for now suffice it
to say that San Francisco is for this
reason and so many countless others
canceled
and that'll do it for the show today
um I'll be at uh Berkeley tonight so
that'll be interesting and if I don't
see you there I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
today on the Ben Shapiro show Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer says
America is not producing enough children
so we must amnesty 11 million illegal
immigrants 12 Republican Senators vote
to enshrine same-sex marriage in federal
law plus SPF the guy from FTX and I said
the quiet part out loud about morality
and stealing money that's today on the
Ben Shapiro show give it a listen